are you now effectively the leader of
the alternative labour party to jeremy
corbyn's if i can put that no i'm the
deputy leader of the labour party and
i've got responsibility for digital
culture media and sport so the
initiative today falls
squarely within my brief and it's
something that i've been looking more
deeply at
when i was actually on the back benches
i was really concerned about the harms
done by fixed odds betting terminals
and actually the industry pushed back at
me and said look you're focusing on
fopties as they called them but you're
doing nothing
in the online space uh why don't you
look at that and i did look at it
and they were right there's a problem
and i think we've got some solutions to
fix it
what about in other areas i mean for
example the anti-semitism chris
williamson
uh being suspended yesterday i mean
suggestion that you basically said if he
isn't suspended
i'm gonna walk with 70 uh
i didn't say that uh although you know
to be very honest with you adam you've
probably seen me up in the volume
frequency of comment on
anti-jewish racism that is conducted by
a small number of labour party members
and i'm doing that because
i've been elected to preserve the
reputation of the labour party which is
a 120 year old institution
with a very proud record of fighting
racism and i'm not going to allow
500 000 members of the labour party be
to be tainted by racism
so when i see cases of anti-semitism
from now on i'm going to be calling it
out
publicly there is an individual
responsibility on all of us in
public life to call it out but there's a
collective responsibility too and that
goes to
members of the shadow cabinet and
members of my national executive
committee and i'm hoping that they will
also step up to
deal with me it is astonishing it's
taken so long for labour to get on top
of this i mean there does seem to be a
fair accusation that even if the
majority of mps the majority of senior
people in the labour party
aren't anti-semitic themselves they are
enabling it or tolerating it within
their ranks
well all i can say is like some of my
colleagues around the shadow cabinet so
john mcdonald for example
you know we have dealt with this problem
too slowly and inadequately
it is obvious that even the changes
we've made
have have not worked we still have
people
using anti-semitic language and
uh being very very unpleasant uh
in this area and i'm not going to take
it uh
i felt personal shame and i thought it
was the most shameful day in the history
of my party
when luciana berger left us she is a
young
pregnant woman bullied out by racist
thugs
and that is completely unacceptable and
you know
when she did that at that point i
realized that i had to step up and i'm
going to be calling this out
day in day out as long as it continues
why not suspend her
constituency labour talking well i've
asked the
general secretary of the party to
investigate goings-on and actually i've
asked the general secretary of the party
to investigate allegations of bullying
in the neighboring constituency
liverpool riverside
where my colleague louise elman
has been the subject of anti-semitic
abuse as well
i mean the people who left were all from
the labour party were all people who
wanted
a second referendum as well so
now that the lab party shifted his
position do you think that was a sort of
a vain gesture if you like or was it
actually what forced the party to shift
its position
for fear of others going the same way i
know there's a lot of complexity and
confusion around it i didn't want anyone
to leave let me just
say that uh but they didn't force us
into this position in fact
our position was it was very sort of
clear
but you and i know that mr corbin and
his office were pretty reluctant about
it
there's definitely levels of sort of
enthusiasm for the second referendum
amongst my colleagues but the conference
decision
negotiated by kia with our members
was very clear there's a number of
hurdles we needed to approach we
preferred a meaningful vote
we would prefer this to be debated in a
general election
we failed on trying to get to there when
theresa may
offered potential concessions we talked
to her we
told her what our red lines were we
prepared to help her with a deal if she
could get closer to
economic alignment we tried to do that
in the chamber last night and we lost
that vote
and so now the final part of our policy
has been triggered which is for this to
be resolved
uh in a people's vote so our policy has
been consistent
by the way that isn't going to stop us
also trying to see whether we can reach
a concessionary position with the
government even though it was rejected
by
parliament last night and how worried
are you about
further splits in the labour party i'm
very worried about it
i i think there are still a number of my
colleagues who are perilously close to
leaving
and i've described this as a battle for
the soul of the labour party
and for lots of reasons all of them
understandable
our front bench you know
is a sort of made up of people who were
prepared to serve under jeremy
when there was a leadership challenge
two years ago and i've been arguing for
some time now that we need to sort of
change the balance on the front bench so
that those
the different traditions that have
formed the labour party can be
more representative do you think they
come back the yvette coopers and people
i i honestly don't know but i do think
we need to sort of go through a process
of trying to
get people back on the front bed if it
can't happen
uh for whatever reason whether jeremy
feels very comfortable with the people
he's got on the front bench now or those
people don't want to come back
that's fine and so what i've suggested
you know is a different way of doing it
which is to bring my colleagues together
who represent
the social democratic tradition to allow
them their own sort of policy space that
they can feed into the policy
let's take something like the suspension
of chris williamson i mean mr corbin was
against that wasn't he
i don't uh actually i don't know what
jeremy's position is
the general secretary is the one that uh
suspended uh
chris williams said i wrote to her and
our chief whip
yesterday morning to say that i
thought there was a strong case that
chris williamson had bought the party
astonishing if you think that and you
don't even know if the labour leader
agrees with you
well i've not spoken to him because he
was in the chamber dealing with the
brexit debate
i have asked him to come and see me next
week where we can talk about what
further measures we can take to
eradicate anti-semitism in the party and
that's the big thing for me
i mean i remember the day you became
deputy leader just uh
over parliament square there you made it
clear that you saw yourself as the
keeper of the conscience of
of all broad labor if i can call it that
rather rather than carbonite labor
could there ever come a point where you
say i simply can't remain in this party
i joined the labour party when i was 15.
you know 200 000 people have made me
deputy leader you would have to drive me
out of the labour party yeah
could you be driven do you think yeah
well they could give it a good go but
that is a good you know i'll be fighting
back if they do
you're not you're not threatening all
the time to leave if you don't get i've
never threatened to leave the labour
party no i mean
it's deputy leader i want i want a
viable electable labor government
and i spent three years as deputy leader
to try and bring everyone together
and you know the tragedy for me the
honest truth is those mps that left
i think we could have avoided that
splinter
and we could certainly have done more to
support my colleague lucy anna berger
before she made that what i think is a
a terrible decision to leave us but
perfectly understandable